one of indiana's largest employers is
sharing its concerns after the state
passed a near total ban on abortions now
indiana is the first state to pass such
a measure since the supreme court
overturned roe v wade the pharmaceutical
giant that's eli lilly and company warn
this we will be forced to plan for more
employment growth outside our home state
as state laws change across the country
now doctors are becoming increasingly
concerned they're very worried about
what they can and cannot do for their
patients so we spoke to four obgyns from
arizona wisconsin ohio and georgia about
how state abortion laws create a lot of
confusion and all of them expressed
concerns and new laws will put their
patients health at risk
as soon as we heard the decision we
closed everything down leaving over 70
women in wisconsin with appointments
that we weren't able to
do for them
we've been preparing it didn't make it
any more devastating i remember asking
when is the law going to change how much
time do we have to get ready for it and
they started to text back and say the
law has actually changed right now i've
lived in the south for most of my life
this is my community
and i'm very concerned about the ability
of my patients my community to access
the care that we need when medicine is
criminalized physicians are scared to do
the jobs they're trained to do
and that absolutely impacts patient care
people are very quick to talk about how
these abortion restrictions have medical
emergency
exceptions but for us as clinicians
actually practicing on the ground those
exceptions just don't really make sense
now many of those options have been
taken away
and
that is just unbearable for all of us
some women will have what we call a
spontaneous miscarriage where they start
to miscarry on their own we have to
counsel them that they may get very sick
that they may develop a life-threatening
infection
and it could potentially cost them their
lives you can't make a one-size-fits-all
definition or law that can take all of
these situations into account we're
seeing issues in labor and delivery for
example of women with pre-viable
pregnancies that come in with infection
that need to be delivered and so there's
a lot of back and forth as to how sick
does the patient need to be to get
delivered does she have to develop an
infection can we intervene before she
develops an infection how sick does she
have to be
before the staff felt comfortable
delivering her because of this law
hanging over our head
if someone who's pregnant comes in after
getting in a car accident or comes in
with an inflamed appendix
are doctors going to be afraid to
get imaging to take them to surgery if
they need surgery because with those
treatments
there is a chance that you could
inadvertently
cause an abortion what if someone has
cancer and they're not gonna die right
then but because they don't receive
abortion care they don't receive the
usual cancer care that they would
receive and thus they die from the
cancer five years later
is that a life that we could have saved
doctors are having to figure out
does this fit under the law am i going
to be criminalized for intervening
i think physicians are afraid that they
will be accused
of providing abortion care when really
they're providing miscarriage management
i think my greatest fear is
how our patients are going to be able to
get the care they need it means so much
to me to be able to take care of my
patients
and
they are suffering because of this
suffering economically suffering
their families are suffering
their futures
will suffer
but some of them are going to die
and they could be saved that's a
travesty
another big concern is misinformation
the doctors say one of them we spoke to
said she heard from a pregnant patient
who is too afraid to get the medical
care why because she fears that her
health will be sacrificed for her unborn
child ob gyns are also concerned that
doctors will now leave their states and
create even more of a health care vacuum
you know the doctors on the ground guys
who are doing the work have a very
important voice in this conversation
they laid out different scenarios i'd
never thought about before yeah they
deal with all the time and we have to
understand because there is no
uniformity there is confusion yeah for
these doctors all the while there's
lives at risk the mother and the baby
yeah it's clearly a lot more complicated
than you think you just read the
headlines and this is this is government
getting in between the relationship of a
patient and their doctor and doctors
don't know what to do right all right
should be sorted out we'll keep
following it in the meantime we will be
right back with more cbs mornings thank
you for watching we appreciate it